just when you think our media and
scientific establishment can't lose any
more credibility on coronavirus they
come around and surprise you doctor foul
Qi remember doctor foul Qi the exalted
one peace be upon him doctor foul Qi
appeared on CNN yesterday to announce
some excellent news they think they've
got a vaccine but there was a caveat the
vaccine might not be all that effective
I doubt seriously that any vaccine will
ever be 100% protected the best we've
ever done is measles which is 97 to 98%
effective oh that would be wonderful if
we get there I don't think we will I
would settle for 70 75 percent effective
vaccine because that would bring you to
that level of would be hurt immunity
level
okay so 70 75 percent effective that's
not great obviously you want it to be
higher than that but look as long as
we're gonna get to hurt immunity that's
where you've got you know so many people
have had the virus that you don't need
to worry about it rampaging through the
whole country anymore as long as you do
that I guess that's a good thing so
we're gonna get hurt immunity right dr.
Fauci right doctor foul Qi unfortunately
maybe not if only say 70 75 percent of
Americans are willing to get the vaccine
and it's only say I think you just said
70 75 percent effective is that going to
get us to hurt immunity no unlikely and
that's one of the reasons why we have to
make sure we engage the community as
we're doing now to get community people
to help us for people to understand that
we are doing everything we can to show
that it's safe and that it's effective
and it's for the good of them as
individuals and in society to take the
vaccine so we have a lot of work to do
because as you well know we've spoken
about this intensively in the past there
is a general anti science at the
authority anti vaccine feeling among
some people in this country an
alarmingly large percentage of people
relatively speaking I can't imagine why
can you imagine why there'd be some
distrust and skepticism of our public
health officials so what he's saying is
that is 75% 70 75 % effective and 70 75
% of people are going to get it and if
that's all that happens we won't get
hurt immunity which means we may not get
a vaccine even if we do get a vaccine it
won't give us herd immunity that means
the only thing we can do is flatten the
curve to avoid overwhelming the hospital
system which we already did we've done
everything we can and yet for some
reason we're all locking down again got
to tell you something folks feels a
little bit to me like we're being played
for suckers
not just on the lock downs not just in
the political arena all the way over at
the Supreme Court - and we got to wake
up because the game seems stacked
against us
[Music]
you
[Music]